well it's not entirely forgotten and for
some people you know it's a very
important book but it is a book that
seems to sort of go underwater to come
up a little and then fall again and it
is June abarnes night would this is a
book that was published in the 30s it's
a tiny little book a dense poetic little
novel I think the current edition still
has TS Eliot's introduction to it a very
enthusiastic one i have read this book
now three times it is a remarkable
little book about passion and you know
sexual passion also that mark that's
sort of living on the margins of a
culture it takes place in Paris and it's
a love story between two women and there
is a character a character that I love
whose name is dr. Matthew O'Connor he's
a transvestite kind of pseudo doctor who
gives some of the most wonderful
speeches in literature my stomach has
grown you guys have been anyway just an
den and and I so when I have a chance I
do come out and say if you haven't read
Juna Barnes's night would I think it is
the only book by the way to recommend by
her I'm not so crazy about the rest of
her work but this is a really
extraordinary unusual little book and
it's not my absolute favorite work of
literature but it's one that I think
people should look at and read more
you